early on thursday about a thousand
marchers took to the streets of yangon
voicing their support for the junta
and its takeover of myanmar's
democratically elected leadership
they were flying the flag of the tapidaw
the official name here for the military
they were met by some protesting against
the coup
later photos appeared to show military
supporters with knives and other weapons
witnesses said they threatened
journalists then came reports of
scuffles
an attack by supporters of myanmar's
junta against anti-coup protesters was
caught
on cctv the video shows a man being
assaulted by an armed group
despite this anti-coup protesters
gathered at the university of yangon
said they will continue with their
peaceful civil disobedience movement
initially police attempted to block them
from leaving the campus
but they made their way out to join
other protesters
a few days after the coup facebook
limited content from myanmar's military
on its platforms
but now it's banned them all together
today we have banned the remaining
myanmar military
also known as the talmud and
military-controlled state and media
entities from facebook and instagram
we've also banned ads from military into
commercial entities
for years myanmar's military has waged a
very sophisticated communications
campaign
weaponizing various social media
platforms and using them to incite and
glorify violence
some feel this move by facebook needs to
be part of an ongoing process
as these accounts have been blocked and
removed
as much as we might laud their removal
we also need to ensure that they are
preserved
and that facebook makes them accountable
for future criminal or
human rights investigation while the
military has used social media platforms
as a tool for its agenda
it also recognizes how vulnerable it
will be if they're taken away
scott heidler al jazeera